[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
today we're finally answering the
question who is the best podcast guest
of all time now before you're like oh
that's so subjective oh how could you
say that whatever these are not my
opinions i'm not reading comments here
we're using cold hard science and math
to figure this out now to make this fair
we're only going to look at comedians
who let's say are more popular as guests
on shows than for their own show and
they all have to appeared on the same
podcast before so those communions are
going to be mark norman andrew schultz
christa stefano christolia and brian
catlin so we're taking those five comics
and looking at their appearances on
three top tier comedy podcasts being
this past weekend with theo vaughn tiger
belly with bobby lee and whiskey ginger
with andrew santino their scores will be
calculated by the amount of views each
episode got divided by the total amount
of subscribers that podcast has
so for example tiger belly has 665 000
subs right and then let's say mark
norman's episode got 1 million views
we'd take that 1 million divided by the
665 000 and get a score of 1.5 the
winner is whoever has the highest
combined score after all three podcasts
it's pretty simple if it doesn't make
sense now i promise it will once we get
more into the video if you're like oh i
just want to see compilations this makes
no sense this is stupid whatever bro
come back monday we're posting theo
vaughn trying not to laugh but for
everyone who really loves comedy who's
really interested in podcasting i
guarantee you'll love this video too uh
so let's just get right into it starting
off with this past week
this past weekend has 945 000
subscribers we're going to start off
with mark norman whose most viewed
episode came two years ago at 1.1
million views which brings us to a score
of 1.164
uh there's nick big nick's a creeper
well he's a premature baby dude so he's
making up for lost oh were you a preemie
well you came out good that's what i'm
saying man why a lot of these guys going
36 and nick got out early bro nick is a
hard worker oh yeah i was like a c-sec
really oh yeah i came out through the
[ __ ] roof
oh wow or i guess maybe this the moon
roof or something
i didn't come out through the door
i could see you being like i don't know
you know is this the best thoroughfare
right let me see what else is going on
and you've all touched your mom's vag i
haven't touched well maybe you've
touched my mom's she's a big [ __ ] andrew
schultz has also been on the show twice
first in episode 180 and the most viewed
episode of 331. that episode had 1.2
million views giving andrew schultz a
this past weekend score of 1.269 i'm tan
bro
i look better tan bro oh you do i think
i look better well you come in a lot
more and i'll be honest with you bro you
come in a lot more
i think mexican bro or [ __ ] beach
slavic
you know
you know what i'm saying like beach uh
croatian
[Music]
you crack them open dude there's a
couple brothers
christopher's best episode was a year
ago episode 265 he racked in 631 000
views for a total this past weekend
score of 0.667 my feet are disgusting
they grow over each other i could easily
see that it's disgusting yeah you almost
you look like somebody who would have
webbed feet almost i don't have web feet
but i believe i was born with broken
feet and they never fixed it yes i just
my feet are broken take care of yourself
dude okay that's what i'm saying you
look like a guy that definitely was in
the band in the school band even though
he wasn't really in it yeah
you look like you were like the marching
thing with the flag yeah yeah dude you
look like my my third grade gym teacher
mrs klein
yeah she was like this lesbian we used
to call liu kang you kind of look like
luke from street fighter if he was a
white dude that had money
thanks man yeah brian kellen first
appeared on episode 183 but his most
viewed episode by far was 325 which had
a million views giving brian calallen a
score of 1.058 somebody said you that
you had four shoulder blades is that
true no it's not true it just looks that
way because i got i got muscle on top of
muscle i'm the first comedian to develop
muscle on top of muscle you understand
that's why the doctor goes i got nothing
to say oh yeah he wrote on my chart
immortal
i don't know if that's good i don't know
if that's good but he looked at my blood
panel and goes well guess you're never
going to die oh you're that hemoglobin
bad boy that's what it is
that's what it is that's why you could
sell my plasma on the black market for
as much as rhino horn goes for you know
what i'm saying jesus christ man people
are getting into that hell yeah i can
cut a diamond with my dick right now
damn dude yeah and we can do that yeah i
stretch up and i stretch oh that's crazy
yeah and i come over and sit on my lap
no way all right whatever this guy's a
[ __ ] baby this guy [ __ ] obviously
i hope this is a manager
chris lee has been on this past weekend
twice first on episode 104 then episode
204 each time getting 1.4 million views
which not only makes him the most viewed
comic out of this past weekend but also
gives him a total score of 1.485 dude
how many waiters at macaroni grill did
you look like over the years
whenever you went in there
honestly
i've i will tell you this straight up
i've never been a macaroni
i know you don't believe me but probably
never been a macaroni probably i know i
know
i know i get it i wouldn't believe me if
a guy like me said i've never been a
macaroni i'd be like get the [ __ ] out of
here i would never trust that guy but
i've never been all right that's the end
of round one let's check the scores we
got crystallia leading right now with
1.48 andrew schultz right behind him at
1.26 mark norman brian callan battling
it out and then chris stefano bring up
the rear at
0.667 tiger belly
[Music]
665 000 subscribers we'll start off with
mark norman again he appeared once on
the show about 10 months ago episode 295
that episode had about 767 000 views on
youtube bringing mark norman's whole
score of 1.153 you look like you [ __ ]
good no
[Laughter]
no no i [ __ ] like my comedy it's stiff
it's quick
yeah it's not pretty not much of an
ending no closer yeah
yeah i'm working on it but it's it's fun
though still huh sex yeah yeah sure
you know i still get to i'm still you
know and as a 50 year old man almost 50.
i still when i'm doing it in my mind i'm
always i'm like a teenager yeah i think
to myself i can't believe i'm doing this
i feel the same way
right and then when they wake up but no
schultz has been on tiger belly twice
episode 226 and 277 his better episode
being the first which had a million
views bringing his tiger belly score to
1.503
you know what i'm also tired of was
talking about food jews no i'm saying
well you go like i went to a mexican i'm
not even jewish by the way but you're
not assuming oh yeah
but anyway um
you know what i also like you're like in
texas and you're in a mexican restaurant
and they go we only use local
ingredients yeah right and it's like
i want guacamole
get the avocado go to vaughn i don't
give a [ __ ]
right
i'm not tired of local ingredients why
are people so proud of that
why are they so proud of the locals
local farmers
here we go and make your farm better and
then everybody
like what are we doing here who are we
joking i don't support local headphones
right
a local cell phone i don't support local
camera like why do we have to support
the local farmer get your [ __ ]
business together get your [ __ ]
business together and then what you'll
do is you'll have something that
everybody wants to buy chris stefano has
been on the show twice once with giannis
pappas and once by himself his solo
episode aired about eight months ago
doing 697 000 views giving him a total
tiger belly score of 1.048 children who
have down syndrome beautiful population
of children yeah to work with they one
of the things with down syndrome is yes
bigger bigger tongues from the
chromosomal deficiencies so yeah you're
saying that you have from abnormalities
big big tongue
tardy let me see it
that's it down syndrome yeah bryan
collins best episode was over four years
ago tiger belly 88. that episode did 702
000 views giving brian callan a tiger
belly score of 1.05 baby step baby
bro bro let me ask you are you a
superstar in korea no nobody knows me
that really that's not at all are you a
[ __ ] superstar in [ __ ] norway or
your [ __ ] people are from he's from
the philippines norway he's from norway
i'm a southern italian and irish
[ __ ] and yes the answer is yes
yeah i went to your house
you probably different house would you
still live in venice or santa monica
which would the one the mansion or the
other man
it was the other imagine this is before
you know what it's pronounced santa
monica
[Laughter]
that brings us to crystalia who has been
an absolute beast on tiger belly he's
been on twice and did over a million
both times the first time being 1.2
million and the most popular time being
1.7 million now chris elias tiger belly
score almost skews the whole graph it's
six can i ask you a question i'm sure
chris deleo all right why do you have
bags under your eyes do you not sleep
good last night i know no you know what
it's the [ __ ] lighting probably but
also i got bags under my eyes but
they're [ __ ] prada dude
i got bags but it's all good i'm
drizzled man i got the [ __ ] [ __ ]
coming out i got salt and pepper coming
in yeah i mean i'm 38 dude what do you
want from me i know you're [ __ ] tall
i'm a tall drink of water and i got bags
underneath it's fine okay that's two
podcasts down one more to go let's check
the leaderboard delia's still in front
we got schultz trailing him and then
callan in the middle christopher stefano
needs to pick it up a little bit and i
expect to see a late push here from mark
norman last but not least whiskey ginger
here
we pour whisk whisk
whisk
[Music]
that creature in the ginger beers
andrew santino has 255 000 subscribers
on youtube we'll start again with the
mark norman episodes he's been on
whiskey ginger twice first episode 57
and then later episode 132. that later
episode had more views than the first
one racking up 340 000 total views
giving mark norman a total whiskey
ginger score of 1.333
repeating
forever what happened to your fanga i
got a cat
scratch me
just i really got a maine [ __ ] why did
you get a cat just so i can say [ __ ]
andrew schultz was on episode 35 and 114
doing very similar scores to mark norman
his highest viewed episode had 338 000
views giving him a total score of 1.132
uh for people that don't know
um you're in the dark schultz is uh
a incredible comedian a good friend and
now he's a
uh uh a top dog on netflix papaya
you were number one dude we were
trending number one we didn't do number
one like globally let's just say it it
was number one we're number one number
one
chris stefano had a whole ass residency
on whiskey ginger he's been on the show
seven times i can never go through all
that information but i will tell you is
that episode 125 was his most viewed
with 435 000 views giving him a total
score of 1.705
and my dad gambled on my gender when i
was born he had to pay my uncle 500
bucks the doctor the the doctor's like
it's a boy who's like it's a girl 10
jesus said talk it back
talk it back
put it back in
yeah now here's where things get a
little bit interesting so far it seems
like crystalia and andrew schultz have
kind of been running away with this but
brian callan on whiskey ginger episode
18 had 600 000 views now with the way
this math works views divided by 12
subscribers this is going to give brian
kellen a huge bomb his whiskey ginger
score is actually 2.35 i met her justin
bieber i've met a lot of the same same
i met a lot of famous people bro i got
these people first of all i did mtv's
punk years ago with those people oh yeah
uh-huh
you name it i did it dude darrell rivas
is a buddy okay do you even know who
that is yeah i played them in college oh
you played college football i did where
what do you mean where where'd you play
college football bry
oklahoma you played at oklahoma yeah
what position before i played miami you
played oklahoma and the u you played at
both of those schools
yeah dude i did
what position
safety
and that brings us to crystalia and i
know you're thinking wait jake christoly
has never been on whiskey ginger what
what's gonna happen now we're gonna sub
it in with something that i kind of view
as equal and also a fan favorite of this
channel i know the church of what's
happening now with joey diaz christoly
appeared on episode 518 of the church
pulling in 344 000 views giving him a
total score of 0.434
this [ __ ] drives me nuts
i get it at shows but like when you're
shooting a special i get a lot of these
and you're like all right i don't need
this [ __ ] for you're stepping on my
punch lines with woos
do you know what i mean these chicks and
and they think they're liking you which
they are but it's like you god it's
going to be able to have a girlfriend
that was a war and i couldn't bring it
to the country
are you out of your [ __ ] mind what
are you doing laugh or don't laugh
that's all i ever want
don't laugh
you're gonna whoo what the [ __ ] you
wanna
you know how [ __ ] stupid you gotta be
the woo
you're [ __ ] stupid you gotta be the
whoop you're not [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] i honestly don't give a [ __ ] if
you're out a [ __ ] angels game you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you will well that
brings us to the final results
chris estefano with 3.42 fourth place
mark norman with a score of 3.65 bronze
medal to andrew schultz with a score of
4.092 the silver medal to brian cowan
4.463 and coming in first place with a
final score of 4.471
the gold medalist the best podcast guest
of all time ladies and gentlemen
crystalia yes obviously not every
comedian was looked at in this video
there's a ton of other great podcast
guests we just did kind of uh five
people that this channel often features
so thanks for watching this video hope
you liked it please go follow us on
instagram we're sending everyone these
free stickers we got the joke world logo
we got what's the deal with airplane
peanuts uh we're featuring a new up and
coming community on there every day it'd
mean a lot if you guys could go blow up
that instagram for me and thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
you